[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro 10 est une culture et
tout de suite le sommaire de ce mercredi
29 mars nous découvrirons le métier de
peintre en décor antoine fontaine
travail pour le trianon à versailles
il participe aux journées européennes
des métiers d'art de la salle de classe
à la scène vanessa caillou n'a pas
hésité depuis quatre ans la professeure
de français du songe où son one woman
show ksenia super active elle sera la
royale factory les 31 mars et 1er avril
prochains les 30 jeunes de trappes ont
participé il ya quelques mois à toi même
film un concours organisé par youtube
ces jeunes sont au coeur d'un
documentaire présenté en impro première
grenier à sel trois jours pour aller à
la rencontre de professionnels
d'exception du 31 mars au 2 avril
ce sont les journées européennes des
métiers d'art et le château de
versailles il participe
les 1er et 2 avril vous pourrez
découvrir ceux qui font vivre le théâtre
de la reine au trianon
comme antoine fontaine peintre en décor
nous l'avons rencontré les images sont
signés michael et demi d'euros un très
précis une esquisse avant de peindre au
bout du crayon en manche et antoine
fontaine peintre décorateur depuis
presque quarante ans vous travaillez sur
le déni de l'époque oui oui bah oui ça
c'est vraiment là
le propos des métiers d'art en tout cas
que je représente cette année s'est
montrée cette technique qui est très
ancien qui a disparu il ya donc très peu
de temps enfin de génération une
génération avant moi qu'il ya des
avantages d'être quand on travaille par
rapport à des décors anciens on retrouve
tout à fait le geste et la technique
la technique c'est celle du travail avec
des pigments de l'eau et de la colle de
peau de lapin la la journée du peintre
commence toujours c'est l'expression
fait chauffer la colle c'est vraiment ça
on doit commencer par chauffer chauffer
la colle
obama risque qui prend une bonne demi
heure pour pouvoir la joindre à la
couleur antoine fontaine l'apprend de
son père peintre lui aussi il voulait
peindre grand pour le spectacle en 2005
il participe à la création des décors de
marie antoinette de sofia coppola
c'est à ce moment que
jean paul roux c'est donc le responsable
du théâtre de la reine et de l'opéra
royal m'a demandé de compléter les
décors qu'il avait ici et puis il a une
superbe forêt dans lequel nous sommes
qui est de six séries 10 1837 qui est
splendide et le lointain et deux plans
de chasse y étaient manquants et m'a
demandé de les recréer ça que ça n'est
pas de la restauration
je fabrique des des objets nouveau c'est
plusieurs répliques ce week-end antoine
répondra aux questions des visiteurs du
trianon et pourquoi pas déclencher des
vocations d'autres savoir-faire seront
aussi à découvrir les métiers de
régisseur encore deux machinistes
n'auront plus de secret pour vous
après les démonstrations proposées un
trait d'humour à présent avec le
spectacle de vanessa caillou elle joue
sur la scène de la royale factory 2
versailles feignasses hyperactive c'est
l'histoire d'une femme qui aimeraient se
détendre mais bien sûr impossible à la
sa vie les impératifs qu'on le que l'on
connaît toutes et tous et c'est une
bouffée d'air frais à vivre sans les
enfants avant le début des vacances
scolaires parti indique t
madame de rénal la vie de point à la
ligne b la guinée par milieux pro vie
il y a encore deux ans vanessa caillou
était professeur de français
alors bien sûr dans son premier
spectacle impossible de ne pas en parler
vous dominicaux qu'une petite pause et
je notais qu'est ce que vous écrivez
madame inquiète tous les jours entre
profs tous les jours il se passe des
trucs énormes
donc tu peux faire j'aurais pu faire
deux heures de spectacle un an là dessus
mais bon après j'ai concentré et j'ai
pas raconté pierre parce que le pire est
jean croirait par heure d'énergie à
revendre et pourtant vanessa caillou et
sur scène une feignasse celles qui
aimeraient être devant sa télé mais qui
a un boulot un enfant annexes et des
factures à payer c'est quand même un
petit peu autobiographique à la base
volière et après c'est le quotidien en
fait c'est l'observation est ce que tu
sais ça c'est j'observe mon enfant
chants sketches
je vais chez gyneco il m'arrive des
trucs j'ai enfin sèche parce que les
fameux 10 et sommes aussi parce que ça
parle aux besoins aussi évidemment en
sortant si mais c'est fin c'est ma vie
que
la réponse est oui en fait on se rend
compte qu'on a plein de points communs
tous un peu vanessa caillou crocs des
instants de vie de tous les jours des
situations parfois il vaut mieux en rire
bien du temps surtout surtout votre
cause est grave de train de banlieue
le soir quand un personne vole arabe ou
alors vive le toit est le sosie daigné
de saint cyr l'école on ne connaît
souvent que la prestigieuse école
militaire arrivé en 1808 dont il reste
aujourd'hui le lycée mais saint cyr
l'école a une histoire la commune a
décidé de consacrer un ouvrage saint cyr
l'école en lumière avec près de 150
pages historiques culturelles et
architecturales
écoutez bernard de bain le maire de la
commune l origine de l ouvrage
c'est une ville qui est riche d'une très
grande histoire et dans lequel de
nombreux événements sont brassés y
compris des événements douloureuse
pendant la dernière guerre et qui a
modifié complètement la topographie de
la ville avec eux les destructions qu'il
y a eu et qui ont fait saint cyr la
ville de martyrs des yvelines une des
villes martyres de toute la france
puisqu'elle a été détruit à 90%
cette semaine c'est gaël pineau du
grenier à sel de trappes qui nous donne
ce qu'on prend son coup de coeur et en
l'écoutant c'est bientôt la troisième
édition du festival play it again play
it again c'est un festival de grands
films classiques du cinéma et ça sera du
5 au 11 avril ces films ont été
restaurés et vous pourrez le découvrir
sur grand écran
nous avons nous au grenier à sel
sélectionné trois de ces défis du
festival il y a tout d'abord pour les
enfants à partir de 5 ans alice comme et
10 c'est un programme des courbes
premier court métrage de walt disney ce
sera le mercredi 5 et le dimanche 9
avril
nous avons aussi les hommes préfèrent
les blondes marie monroe sera donc au
grenier à sel le vendredi 7 avril et le
troisième film sera indochine avec
catherine deneuve et vincent perez le
film a été restauré en ultra haute
définition 4k et ce sera le dimanche 9
avril à 20h45 vous retrouver tout ça sur
notre site internet cinéma grenier à sel
points comme je vous dis à bientôt
on revient maintenant sur une
avant-première l'unique diffusion dans
une salle de cinéma
et cet attrape qu'elle a eu lieu la
semaine dernière à youtube présenter le
documentaire toi même tu filmes duffy du
concours du même nom 30 trappistes ayant
participé regarder alors aujourd'hui le
trou c'est parce que nous allons
visionner il ya un documentaire
projection particulière ce soir là au
grenier à sel de trappes certains
spectateurs vont se voir à l'écran ils
ont été filmées lors de leur
participation au concours toi même tu
filmé cette aventure sinon c'est
vraiment une apporte une aventure
superbe
c'est vraiment un espace à faire pour
tous les jeunes ou les jeunes
investissent fait même on connaît pas la
meilleure façon de faire et ils nous ont
donné la wind est une des meilleures
façons
hélas
une des meilleures aussi parce qu'on
utilise tous les jours c'est notre
téléphone j'ai appris que c'était un
concours vidéo et moi je skie et cinéma
vidéo bas sans pas femmes intéressant
play pendant plusieurs mois ces jeunes
ont réalisé des courts-métrages encadrés
par les équipes de youtube 90 secondes
autour d'un même message la fraternité
le réalisateur mathieu mast ans et qui
sait parmi eux et en ressort 40 minutes
de documentaires l'idée c'est de voir un
peu les coulisses de la tournée donc les
ateliers avec les jeunes qui consistait
à un volet pédagogique un volet plus
ateliers de travail où on allait
travailler ensemble à créer des vidéos
et les équipes de youtube seront à
nouveau dans l'école lunel et et 2017
les trappistes les attentes déjà on
reste à trappes mais on part à l'école
de musique et de danse pour un spectacle
le chaos des mots est un match
d'improvisation littéraire imaginé par
albert droff sonia prévost et alain
degois plus connu sous le nom de papi le
principe deux concurrents se font face
et doivent rédiger en cinq minutes un
texte à thème sur ordinateur le public
suit en direct leurs créations et ses
samedis 1er avril à 16 heures
on débute cet agenda avec une pièce de
théâtre l'histoire de ronald caron
michael qui est un auteur à succès qui
cherche à remplacer son collaborateur le
jour de son mariage c'est le point de
départ de la fille sur la banquette
arrière et on regarde un extrait je ne
crois pas que nous connaissions
je suis confus mademoiselle permettez
moi de vous présenter papillon c'est
alison je n'ai pas bien compris votre
nom mademoiselle craddock et ma nouvelle
partenaire des piquants depuis
maintenant merveilleux nous aurons le
même anniversaire nous fêtons ensemble
j'espère que vous restez mon mariage
cherry toi je sais que tu restes théâtre
encore est l'histoire d'un amour
impossible celle dont dean une nymphe
des eaux qui éprouve un amour passionné
pour un chevalier hans la compagnie du
catogan la propose au théâtre des
arcades de buc regardes et tu t'appelles
[Musique]
des tiges un jour de 15h et le fus ce
qu'on attende
[Musique]
cette année c'est le côté seigneur n ya
pas d usage roadshow molina danseuse et
chorégraphe espagnol sera ce vendredi
sur la scène du prisme à elancourt elle
propose une relecture du flamenco
traditionnel
regardez
[Musique]
on termine avec un rendez vous du côté
de voisins-le-bretonneux mais ta sauce
vous propose une soirée hip hop samedi
1er avril trois groupes seront à la
salle de la tour le cetud culture est
maintenant terminée je vous remercie de
nous avoir suivis vous pouvez regarder
cette émission en replay sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile
quant à moi je vous dis à mercredi
prochain
[Musique]